SPEAKER 1: Kubeflow
pipelines are made up
of a series of components
that give you an ML workflow.
Naturally, you'll want to
improve those workflows
over time, like their
performance, efficiency,
and accuracy.
Kubeflow metadata is a central
thing to help you do just that.
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link
below to read more
about metadata on Kubeflow.
The goal of the
metadata project is
to help Kubeflow users
understand and manage
their machine learning workflows
by tracking and managing
the metadata that the
workflows produce.
Not only is it useful
to improve your results,
but it's important for
audit and compliance reasons
so you can know which
models are in production
and what their
characteristics are.
Here, metadata means
information about executions,
or runs, models, data
sets, and other artifacts.
Artifacts are the
files and objects
that form the inputs and outputs
of the components in your ML
workflow.
Kubeflow comes with
a metadata component
installed by default, which is
used for storing and serving
metadata.
You can write to the metadata
server from your own code.
And in addition, some
Kubeflow components
log metadata about their
activities automatically.
Then the Kubeflow UI lets
you view the logged metadata.
In particular, Kubeflow
pipelines automatically
log information about a run,
including workflow artifacts,
executions, and lineage.
You can see this pipelines
feature in action
with the Cloud AI platform's
Pipelines Installation.
Models and data sets can then be
visualized in the metadata web
UI so that you can start
tracking them out of the box
with no extra work required.
You just need to
head to the Artifact
Store in the left-hand panel.
Behind the scenes, Kubeflow
is handling the metadata
through ML MD, a library
for recording and retrieving
metadata.
ML MD is an integral part
of TensorFlow Extended.
But it's designed to
be used independently.
Kubeflow helps you use metadata
for all components of your ML
workflow.
It comes with a metadata API
and corresponding clients.
And you install
the metadata SDK,
a Python library that makes it
easy to write to the metadata
server.
Kubeflow Pipelines
automatically logs metadata
during a pipeline run.
This lets you track the
definition of artifacts
for things like
pipeline versions
and when they were last
updated, the metadata
to evaluate an execution
of your pipeline,
like the run ID
inputs and outputs,
and the metadata about the
pipeline and associated
lineage information,
so you can clearly
see how artifacts and
their associated metadata
relate to one another.
In addition to Kubeflow
Pipelines automatic tracking,
you can manually write
to the metadata server
to collect additional metadata
like the metadata for a data
set that forms inputs and
outputs, like a description,
path, and query; metrics
used to evaluate an ML
model, like the accuracy
and learning rate;
and the metadata for an ML model
that your workflow produces,
like the model type, hyper
parameters and labels.
Let's walk through an example of
writing to the metadata server.
I'm running a sample
[INAUDIBLE] classifier model
in my Jupyter Notebook server.
After I execute a run, I
can log a data set, model,
evaluation of the model, and
metadata for serving the model.
Once I'm in the
Artifact Store, I
can see a list of items
for all the metadata events
that my workflows have logged.
I can see an example
of the model, metrics,
and data set metadata with
the name mytable-dump.
Besides using the SDK to
log metadata directly,
you can also add your
own metadata watcher
to watch Kubernetes
resource changes.
It extracts metadata from
some Kubernetes API objects
and logs them to the
Kubeflow metadata service.
To learn more and
try out this notebook
and explore its metadata,
check out the links below.
And stay tuned to learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]